ever crack bonjour on vous retrouve en
direct de Kiev on a vu donc c'est scène
de joie dans les zones séparatistes donc
prorus il faut nuancer la population
dans l'ensemble du gambas et t'inquiète
parce que la guerre pourrait éclater à
tout moment en fait
oui exactement c'est actuellement divisé
entre deux parties une partie qui est
contrôlée par les séparatistes soutenus
par la Russie une partie qui est
contrôlé par le gouvernement
ukrainien et de chaque côté on peut
trouver des gens qui ont des sentiments
plus pro ukrainiens et des gens qui ont
des sentiments prorus mais ce qui les
unit en ce moment je pense que c'est
plus la peur qu'autre chose c'est scène
de Liège il y en a un sans doute eu un
petit peu à loin ce qui a internet mais
même là ce que je vois sur les réseaux
sociaux ce que je sais des autres médias
qui ont des correspondants sur place et
des contacts que je peux avoir c'est que
le sentiment prédominaux c'est un
sentiment de très grande inquiétude
quand aux opérations militaires qui vont
peut-être avoir lieu et qui sont déjà en
cours il y a des tirs sur toute la ligne
de front donc des gens des deux côtés
des 6 fils des deux côtés souffrent côté
séparatiste il y a eu ses évacuations
forcées en partie en tout cas les gens
qui évacuer n'était pas du tout contente
d'après les témoignages que j'ai pu lire
des correspondants sur place et de notre
propre correspondant aussi qui est côté
russe on sait que ces évacuations ne se
sont pas passées très bien donc je pense
que ce n'est pas vraiment la grande Lyes
même du côté de donuts et de loin et
côté nord côté contre les par le
gouvernement là il y a clairement un
grand sentiment de peur ce matin j'ai pu
joindre une habitante de chassia une
ville juste au nord de Louane ce que mes
contrôlé par l'Ukraine ou la centrale
électrique a été le cible de missile
aujourd'hui encore une fois c'est une
femme qui m'avait dit il y a quelques
jours encore qu'elle n'avait aucune
intention de partir aujourd'hui elle m'a
dit que finalement si elle pense que
c'est le moment de quitter les lieux
pour sa propre sécurité et qu'elle
n'était pas du tout la seule dans la
ville à le penser on a discours de
Vladimir Poutine qui a été suivi en
Ukraine en Russie bien sûr la question
du jour Gulliver c'est de savoir si les
soldats russes ont passé la hier on ne
sait toujours pas
non officiellement non le ministère des
Affaires étrangères russes a dit que il
n'avait pas l'intention d'envoyer les
soldats pour le moment mais dans le
document signé par Vladimir Poutine
reconnaissant l'indépendance de ces deux
pseudo République là il y ait été écrit
que la Russie enverrait une équipe
soi-disant de maintien de la paix on a
vu beaucoup de vidéos circulaires de
char de véhicule militaire circuler dans
Donald Clouange que d'autres régions
contre les par les séparatistes d'autres
villes donc il y a beaucoup d'activités
militaires mais on ne peut pas confirmer
indépendamment si ce sont des véhicules
russes nouvellement arrivé ou juste les
véhicules russes qui étaient juste déjà
là depuis 2014 ils sont là en réalité
seulement ce n'était ce n'était pas
officiel merci beaucoup pour ces
éléments Gulliver crack depuis Kiev pour
France